Speaker 1: We now have video of former Breitbart
propagandist and former Trump advisor Steve
Bannon, who at one point was participating in
meetings with the National Security Council over
the backwards nature of how these absolutely
horrible people, 50 to 60 years from now,
when this error is studied and people like Steve
Bannon, Jared Kushner and Steven Miller are part
of the discussion of history of the people
that had influence at this point in time.
Let's hope the future forgives us. Steve
Bannon now has admitted that he helped plan
the January six Trump rally that ultimately
led to the Trump riots in order to kill the
Biden presidency in the crib. That's the phrase he
used. We're going to look at a clip momentarily.
Trump White House chief strategist
Steve Bannon said he spoke with Trump
ahead of his rally on six January discussing how
to, quote, kill the Biden. Nancy, in the crib
shortly before a pro Trump mob laid siege to the
Capitol to stop the certification of President
Joe Biden's election victory. During a broadcast
on Real America's Voice, Mr. Bannon played a clip
from MSNBC of Washington Post reporters Robert
Costa and Robert Woodward speaking about the
events that led up to the capital riot. Let's pick
this up at exactly that point in the broadcast.
Speaker 4: Talking to you that night, Steve Bannon
on the phone. He's telling Steve Bannon over at
the Willard Hotel, we need to kill the Biden
presidency in the crib. That was the phrase
based on our reporting in that conversation.
Speaker 5: Yeah, because of legend, say,
let's look at the economist, Paul The Economist,
not the war room, not revolver, the economists,
42 percent of the American people, 42 percent of
the American people think that Biden did not win
the presidency legitimately. Mm hmm. It killed
itself. That's why this debt ceiling fight,
the C.R. fight so, so important. That's why
getting in exposing to the world the Mogadishu
situation in Del Rio, Texas, particularly for
all the hard working Hispanic, blue collar
Hispanics in this country, American citizens.
Speaker 1: Let me talk about that briefly. That's
actually we could do a half hour just on that. The
the the hard working working class, blue collar
Hispanic American citizens there is. So Steve
Bannon is is a horrible reactionary, but Steve
Bannon is part of a slice of the right that
recognizes, particularly in states like Texas,
you're going to need to appeal to Hispanic
voters if you want to continue winning those
states. And in fact, Trump did OK with
Hispanic voters. If you look at Florida,
I know Cubans are particularly right wing Hispanic
voters, but he did OK in Florida. Actually, he won
Florida, thanks in part to a pretty strong level
of support from from Cuban-American Floridians.
Steve Benen understands that. And that's why now
you're starting to see people like Bannon placate
and sort of pay lip service to working class
American Hispanics who are American citizens. That
is, you know, it's dangerous in the sense that if
they succeed, it will allow them to hold some of
these states longer than than all else being equal
they otherwise might be able to. So we're going to
come back to that. But that's when you might be
wondering why all of a sudden, as Steve Benen
talking about, you know, appealing to Hispanic
voters, it's because he is part of a slice that
recognizes what's going on and that they need
those voters in order to keep winning places
like Florida, Texas, maybe even other states.
Speaker 5: Just let this go with this illegitimate
regime is doing it killed itself. OK, but we
told you from the very beginning, just expose it.
Just expose it. Never back down, never give
up. And this thing will implode. And we'll
see in doing so, we will save our country.
Speaker 1: So not denying there that he was
involved and talking to Trump
about that they had this plan.
He is basically saying here the plan was
justified, the plan was justified because
a lot of Americans never believed or don't
believe or still don't believe or were convinced
that Joe Biden didn't actually win the election.
The whole point here was to expose this and to
expose it early and to expose it from day one.
So that is Steve Bannon not denying that, saying,
yeah, we were justified in organizing that rally,
the rally, which eventually led, of course, to the
to the riots and by the way, considered the double
standard. Right. There's the double standard of
we absolutely had to plan that rally because Joe
Biden either stole the election or was already
setting us up for disaster, whatever. And at
the same time, the rioters were really antifa.
They were they weren't really trumpet's. But we
did plant we planned the rally, but the rioters
were fake and we were justified in one, but we had
absolutely nothing to do with the other. Come on,
guys, come on. Last thing, kill it in the crib is
weird phraseology for a supposedly anti-abortion
group of people. There's something a little bit
odd about that phrase, but maybe we won't get
into that right now. We'll have more coverage and
clips from this very strange Steve Bannon show
on our Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman show on Instagram.